des images que nous avions diminue
d'expérience immersive au sein de la
Villa Savoie c'est ce que viennent de
tester ces personnes à l'aide d'un
casque de réalité virtuelle les
visiteurs ont pu remonter à l'époque des
années 30 et comprendre la genèse de la
Villa Savoie c'est pour nous vraiment la
possibilité de proposer aux visiteurs
une expérience complémentaire de de sa
visite à la villa et grâce à la réalité
virtuelle de lui donner à voir et à
comprendre et l'histoire de la Villa
Savoie parce qu'on remonte le temps et
puis également les principes
d'architecture du Corbusier cette visite
est le fruit d'un travail de plus de 18
mois réalisé en collaboration avec le
studio lucide realities les visiteurs
peuvent observer l'évolution du site
grâce à des archives de la Fondation Le
Corbusier et entendre les échanges entre
Eugénie Savoie et l'architecte
par rapport à une visite traditionnelle
qu'on peut faire avec un audioguide
quand même en visite libre donc oui très
très intéressant ce qui est très
impressionnant c'est de voir le terrain
avant avec une vue absolument splendide
de voir aussi des aspects de
construction de plans l'expérience VR
s'adresse à tous la visite peut
également se faire en anglais et en
public beaucoup plus variés qui vient à
la Villa Savoie maintenant grâce à cette
expérience qui ne sont pas forcément des
fanas d'architecture ou de Le Corbusier
mais qui vont être attirés par cet
aspect virtuel et très moderne la visite
est au prix de 4 roues et est ouverte
tous les week-ends